The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
EARLL MURMAN: OK, the
title of this module
is Improving the Enterprise.
And just to put
it in context, we
inherited a poorly
performing clinic.
We have applied lean,
what we call local lean.
But now we're going
to look at, how
do you handle issues that are
outside the span of control
of the clinic?
And this is where
you usually end up.
That's the objective for
the rest of the afternoon,
with the exception of the very--
at very end, we're
going to tee you up
on a homework assignment.
OK, so if you want to
improve the whole enterprise,
you can't just do it locally.
You'll end up suboptimizing
the enterprise.
You may optimize
yourself locally,
but you'll suboptimize
the enterprise.
So we want to work through
on how organizations
can adapt to external
constraints and implement lean.
And the mode we're
going to do this
is something called a rapid
process improvement workshop,
which is one way to
implement lean across a wider
group than what you have here.
We're going to look at
including a daily management
system, which is a
little bit of an add-on.
And then we're going to see we
have some trouble doing that,
and we'll discuss it.
OK, so just to frame this,
health care operations
are often impacted
by decisions which
are outside the
control of the clinic.
I mean, this is
regulations, insurance,
resource constraints.
We had something
earlier this afternoon,
where we had some
change of employees.
It was beyond the
purview of the clinic.
We had to adjust for that.
That was a disruptive
thing we had to handle,
which is not unusual.
And we need to optimize
at the enterprise level,
as I've already said.
Otherwise, we may not optimize
across our whole enterprise.
OK, I think this has
already been contained.
What I'd really like to
do is get some examples
from your own experience.
Or what are some external
things that you've
experienced that have disrupted
your enterprises you work with?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, just patients
showing up all in one bunch.
Like when I was on triage
as a medicine resident,
all of our admissions would show
up at 4:30 in the afternoon.
Because everyone was coming
to the ER in the afternoon.
And then, by the time
they got worked up,
that load would hit the
medicine admitting team at 4:30.
So it's kind of the--
EARLL MURMAN: So yeah,
this is a classic thing,
isn't it, that the one
department in the enterprise
impacting the other department.
And it's out of your control.
And of course, yeah, exactly.
And it can happen the other
way, too, that the admissions,
they're not being admitted
into the hospital.
So they're piling up in the
ER and affecting the ER.
OK.
Other things?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EARLL MURMAN: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Funding.
EARLL MURMAN: Funding.
OK, so resources--
here's the thing, where
you know you can do something.
You want to do something, but
you can't get the funding.
Or maybe you get the funding,
and then there's a reduction.
I mean, that's happening
in my local hospital
now in Washington state.
The state's grappling with a $2
billion budget shortfall gap.
And they provide
basic health coverage
for underemployed
people in the state.
I live in a rural community.
My hospital has a
lot of these people.
They're about ready to
lose all that money,
and they still have
to treat the patients.
OK.
It's beyond their control.
I mean, they can go down to
Olympia and lobby a little bit.
But basically, it's
beyond their control.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I've been working
on a telephone operations
improvement project recently
with an ancillary department,
where we only have
three front desk staff.
And our intervention
was to separate
one of the front
phones in the back area
and then have just the
front desk staff locked
at the front, directly
interact with patients,
and not have to worry
about phone calls.
And in doing our pilot, to the
two-week PBSA pilot, some days,
we only had one staff
actually show up to work.
So obviously, our plan
didn't go as it would have,
if we had the three staff.
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah.
So there you got
an employee issue.
Yeah.
It might have
unreliable employees,
or maybe there are complications
in their family life,
that they couldn't
come or whatever.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] sick.
EARLL MURMAN: Sick, yeah.
Any other examples?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The
recession-- our economics
and how it affects our
patients [INAUDIBLE]..
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah, I mean, we
can't control the world, right?
We're in an environment
imposed on us,
and we have to deal with it.
Yeah.
Any examples you can think of?
AUDIENCE: Space constraints.
EARLL MURMAN: Space constraints.
AUDIENCE: When your capacity
exceeds your [INAUDIBLE]..
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah, just
not enough facilities.
OK, so these are not
unusual disruptions.
OK, so we say this
is a statement.
I suppose it may be
more of a hypothesis.
But the lean organizations,
by their nature,
are maybe more
adaptable to change
than other organizations.
First of all, you're
process-oriented.
You think about processes.
You think less about side
or turfs or rice bowls,
or those kinds of things.
You get process-oriented
and think about,
how do you change your process?
If you have standardization,
which you should
if you're a good
lean organization,
it means you're going to
have fewer things to change.
You have a stable base
on which to change,
as opposed to many things
that have to be changed.
You're used to thinking of
things in rapid cycle times.
And that's going to be really
this whole rapid process
improvement workshop,
adapting to change quickly.
And you just have
a culture where
you're accepting of change.
Lean is a Journey.
You're always changing.
You're always trying
to get better.
So you're not fearful of change.
So these are all things that,
in terms of a lean organization,
help you in dealing with
these external constraints.
Just to anchor this back in this
process improvement framework
we've been using-- and by
the way, a copy of this
is in your folders, just
for your reference purposes.
And why we put it
there is to try
to impart a thought process of
structured approach to change
and not ad hoc
approach to change.
So this is one
structured approach.
There are many other
structured approaches.
This is one that we adopted,
just to give you one.
And right now, we're in here.
We're going to be doing another.
We're going to have
some changes we're
going to introduce to you.
They're going to be
beyond your control.
And we're going to
have to figure out
how to respond to them,
develop an implementation plan,
and try it out.
And in doing this, as you
go beyond your clinic,
you're going to have to
interact with a wider
group of stakeholders.
And that's part of
the complexity of it.
We've heard from Beau, for
example, already about that.
So let's talk a little
bit about stakeholders.
We had this slide up yesterday
in a slightly different format.
But a health care
enterprise like yours
has a lot of stakeholders.
And let's just try to identify,
in the interest of time
and keeping this focus,
for our clinics here,
who are our major stakeholders?
AUDIENCE: Patients.
EARLL MURMAN: Patients, OK.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Suppliers.
EARLL MURMAN: Suppliers, OK.
AUDIENCE: Providers.
AUDIENCE: Providers and
doctors and the medical staff.
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah, so you
have the staff, medical staff.
Why don't we just put
all the staff together.
There's the medical
and the administrative.
For now, let's
just call it staff.
Any other stakeholders in our
simulated clinic environment?
AUDIENCE: Investors?
EARLL MURMAN: Investors, OK.
AUDIENCE: The government.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
The government is an
important stakeholder,
but probably not so much for
our classroom environment here.
But there is another
important-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Oh,
whoever's regulating.
EARLL MURMAN: We've
got management.
It's called managers--
CFO or CMO, or whatever it is.
You've got somebody
you're reporting to.
They keep imposing new
things on you and saying,
you can't do this,
you can't do that.
AUDIENCE: You've got
the payers as well.
EARLL MURMAN: Payers, OK.
We haven't actually collected
any money from them yet. .
OK, this is a pretty good group.
So let's just stay
with that group.
But you can imagine, in a
more complex enterprise,
you're going have more people.
You'll have regulators.
You might have partners.
My hospital, for example,
can't do a number of procedures
as a small hospital.
So partners with
Swedish Hospital,
in Seattle, and Harrison
Hospital, in Bremerton,
these are important
stakeholders; EMS systems.
They're all sorts
of other partners.
Now, we had this slide
up yesterday, too.
But each of these stakeholders
expects some value
from your enterprise.
So let's just think,
what value do patients
expect from your clinic?
AUDIENCE: Quality.
EARLL MURMAN: Quality.
OK, so remember, we've
been doing that managements
ask you, every so often,
did some patient get
treated incorrectly?
That's a concern
they track that.
AUDIENCE: Affordability.
EARLL MURMAN: Affordability.
OK.
Maybe we should introduce
a pay for service,
pay for performance
option in this simulation.
We haven't done that yet.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Quick access?
EARLL MURMAN: Access, yep.
Access-- they want
to get treated.
AUDIENCE: The time.
EARLL MURMAN: Time?
AUDIENCE: Time.
EARLL MURMAN: Time.
OK.
That's a metric
we've been tracking.
AUDIENCE: Safety [INAUDIBLE].
Safety.
EARLL MURMAN: Safety.
Yeah, it's a little
bit related to quality,
but we'll put it here.
OK, how about the suppliers?
What are they?
And by the way, also,
this is a two-way street.
I mean, they expect value,
and you expect value.
Suppliers-- what are some
of the value considerations
that come in with suppliers?
AUDIENCE: Accuracy?
You got the order accuracy.
EARLL MURMAN: Accuracy, OK.
AUDIENCE: Timeliness.
EARLL MURMAN: Timeliness.
AUDIENCE: Cost.
EARLL MURMAN: Cost.
And what do you expect
from your suppliers?
What value do you expect to get?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Quality.
EARLL MURMAN: Quality.
AUDIENCE: Reliability,
in both ways, I guess,
that they rely on a
steady stream of orders.
EARLL MURMAN: Oh, OK.
And you rely on them
delivering it when you need it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I mean, they don't want you
to go to their competitors.
EARLL MURMAN: Are you guys
happy with your suppliers?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Generally.
EARLL MURMAN: If you had
to rate 0 to 10, how would
you rate your
suppliers, 0 to 10.
AUDIENCE: 8.
EARLL MURMAN: 8.
AUDIENCE: Probably
just a [INAUDIBLE]..
5.
[LAUGHTER]
EARLL MURMAN: Our
supplier just joined us.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, what value do
the staff expect?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EARLL MURMAN: What do you want
to get out of your clinic?
AUDIENCE: Not
feeling overloaded.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
You want an acceptable workload.
AUDIENCE: Just then
value-added work.
EARLL MURMAN:
Value-added work, OK.
Do you feel like they're
doing value-added work now?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
EARLL MURMAN: Yes?
Good.
All right.
Thinking back to the exercise
in the people module yesterday
about some of the things
you value as employees--
you're the staff--
what are things
that come to mind?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] respect.
EARLL MURMAN: Respect.
AUDIENCE: Cooperation.
EARLL MURMAN: I know
it's most the clinics are
working overtime.
Is that something you like?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
or something.
[LAUGHTER]
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah, salary
was important, too, wasn't it?
AUDIENCE: Communication.
EARLL MURMAN: Communication.
OK.
I'll show you a little
later on a slide.
But my local hospital, what the
staff picked is their measure.
Their surrogate metric they
track for their satisfaction
is finishing work on time
and not taking anything home.
That was the one
metric they track.
And they tracked that metric.
AUDIENCE: Safety to [INAUDIBLE].
EARLL MURMAN: Safety, yes.
AUDIENCE: And [INAUDIBLE].
EARLL MURMAN: Oh, teamwork,
teamwork-- got you.
OK, so there's a long list here.
OK, let's not spend too
much more time on this.
Let me just skip these two,
because they aren't really
too much players in our system.
But what about our management?
What are they looking for?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
EARLL MURMAN:
Perform [INAUDIBLE]..
Performance.
We've got some metrics
up here they're tracking.
We know they're
tracking performance.
We're measuring it in
terms of patients served.
We're looking at error
safety, basically, or errors,
like quality.
OK.
Legal reliability.
EARLL MURMAN: Reliability.
AUDIENCE: Legal liability.
EARLL MURMAN: Oh,
legal liability.
AUDIENCE: Patient
satisfaction [INAUDIBLE]..
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah,
they don't want
to hear from angry patients.
Luckily, our patients
aren't talking.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
Patient satisfaction.
OK, well, I just
wanted to make--
we wanted to bring
some of these out.
And we're going to
start addressing them.
So let's move on.
I'm going to skip the next
slide, which is our discussion
slide, which we just did.
I'm going to put this up here.
But we're not going to spend
much time on ideal state now.
Because we're a little
behind schedule.
But we have a value stream.
We have an improved
value stream.
And we've talked before about
thinking of the ideal state
value stream.
And this is a nice quote that
comes from Sue's partner, Cindy
Jimmerson, whose book I
recommend to you, that this is
what the ideal state would be.
"Giving the customers
exactly what they want,
when they want it, is a core
principle of an ideal state."
OK, well, our customers,
our main customers,
are our patient.
So this is what we would really
like to do for our patient.
So "as you observe
work in progress,
note the delays in care
created by caregivers
waiting for the necessities
from their suppliers."
Now, we don't have a
lot of suppliers here.
But we have had
to wait for them.
But that kind of delay
is just passed on.
So this is another reason.
If you want to optimize the
performance of your clinic
or improve it,
you're probably going
to have to include
your suppliers.
That's very common.
I'm going skip over this.
OK, so that's just some
sort of framing discussion
for what we're going to do.
Now, management's told
me-- and the reason
they had me come today
to do some training,
because management told
me that there are going
to be some disruptions coming
soon from the enterprise,
from these CXOs.
And they wanted me to get
you ready for handling those.
OK, so this is going to
involve working across clinics
to handle these disruptions.
By the way, in terms
of access, and we
have a problem with
access here, some patients
aren't being treated.
We don't have the right
diagnostic equipment.
So we're sending
them home untreated.
And the management's
not happy about that.
The patients are
unhappy about that.
So how do we go about
working across clinics?
OK, a good way to
do it is something
called a rapid process
improvement workshop.
And what is that?
Well, that's a focus on
a specific improvement
opportunity, as
we're going to have
coming up here in a minute.
It's an event that's
chartered by a sponsor
in the organization, one
of the managements, who
sets the goals, the what has to
be done, and the constraints,
and provides the resources.
And the resources are--
we'll get to those in a minute.
But they're mainly people.
They provide coaches and
facilitators to help you.
A rapid process
improvement workshop
never goes over a week.
Most of them are a week long.
Sometimes they're less, if
it's a less complex problem.
But it takes several months of
planning to get ready for this.
And what it does is
it brings together,
for the week, all the people
who need to interact to address
this improvement opportunity.
And the opposite of that
is that these people--
the contrast would be that
these people are mainly
doing their day jobs,
wherever they are,
and you're trying to
do this improvement
opportunity over a
distributed group of people
in time and space.
And what might take six months
to a year just to coordinate,
you get done in one week.
But in that week, that's
all these people do.
They're released from all
their other activities,
and they participate in this.
And this is the kind
of thing that Sue does.
I presume you run
these, don't you?
AUDIENCE: Some of them.
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
OK, so it involves
all the stakeholders.
It's a very data-driven process.
We've been trying to
emphasize you work with data.
You get the value-stream data.
The week ends with actually a
beginning of an implementation
and a plan for final
implementation.
And so this is how you get
a whole enterprise together
by getting the right people.
This is an example of one
I've drawn these slides from,
where I sat through with this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you're
actually implementing.
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah,
we actually implement.
But we implement,
but there may be
additional training and other
things that need to be done.
And we'll show you
that in a minute.
Here's diagrammatically
what that is.
So we have a rapid process
improvement workshop
that's going to be
three to five days, say.
And it starts by
understanding what
is important to improve
in the enterprise.
And there's always more
to improve than resources.
So you do some kind
of Pareto chart.
We've done that informally
with this kind of thing we had,
which was, what were the big
bottlenecks you had to address?
So you pick some target.
You make a strategic choice on
what you're going to improve.
And then you may take three
months or so to get ready.
You have to go out
and get the data.
You have to figure out who
are the right stakeholders.
You have to plan it so the
stakeholders can be available.
You're going to pour a lot
of resources in for one week.
But you'll probably pour
a lot less resources
than if you try to stretch
it over six months to a year.
PROFESSOR: And the agreement has
to be that the stakeholders do
not leave the room,
turn off cell phones,
and they're cloistered
for the whole time.
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah.
And they don't arrive late,
and they don't go back
to some other meeting.
That's it.
And that's why you need
this top level support.
OK, then that group
is given a charter.
And they're given the
resources they need
and the data they need.
And that's a really
intense week.
Has anybody participated in
one of these rapid process
improvement workshops?
Sue, Sue and I, and Hugh.
You think this course
is maybe intense.
These are much more
intense than that.
But the outcomes are great.
So out of that comes your future
state and implementation plan.
And as Sue said, you actually
do the prototype implementation
in place.
Sometimes you can't do
the final implementation.
And then you track
it and make sure
that it's performing
the way you think.
And oftentimes,
you've misjudged.
You made a mistake somewhere.
Training is a typical one.
You didn't get people
trained properly,
or something like that.
And so you may have to
do some follow-up action.
And then you feed that back in
and do the next rapid process
improvement event.
Who are these stakeholders?
Well, you want to have the
people actually doing the work.
In this case, that's you.
OK?
You want to have some
facilitators and coaches.
That's Beau and me.
And you might think of
Hugh as our sponsor.
If we were doing
something where suppose
we're going to implement
some new protocol.
Well, we need people from the
training department to come.
We may need some IT people
to write some software.
If we're doing
something more physical,
we might have
facilities on board.
They just saw down the
walls and move them,
right during the week.
I mean, this is really
action-oriented.
OK, so you may need
some support facilities.
And you want somebody up
there at the CEO level
who's championing it.
And here's what takes
place during the week.
So day one-- this
is for a five-day--
you come together.
You do some team-building.
Make sure you're all being
able to work with each other.
You go to the Gemba and
actually see what's happening,
make sure you understand
what the real problem is.
You'll probably come in with a
current state map already done,
because that takes some time.
And you do a lot
of brainstorming.
How are we going to address this
improvement opportunity that
is given to us in our charter?
So day one is really
getting started.
Day two-- go home and sleep out.
You come back on day
two, and you say, OK,
from our brainstorming, we
think this is the way we can go.
Here's going to be our draft
future state map and strategy.
And you have senior
management come
in the afternoon of day two
and say, here's where we're at.
And this is the
direction we want to go.
Do we have your approval?
Let me give you the example I
went through in this one, which
the pictures are taken from.
This was, how do we treat
STEMI cases in our hospital?
And our hospital
can't do a catheter--
doesn't have a catheter lab.
And the treatment time
was from a presentation
to when they were getting
finally sent down to Bremerton.
Treated was-- I've forgotten,
something like several hours.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EARLL MURMAN: Pardon?
EARLL MURMAN: STEMI
is S T Elevated--
AUDIENCE: S T segment elevation.
It's higher tech.
EARLL MURMAN: It's a
blockage [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: A research
pattern that shows up,
a leakage [INAUDIBLE] right now.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
So we gathered on day one.
And we immediately
found out, on day one,
there was a constraint
that was so great,
we couldn't solve the problem.
And that was, we
simply physically
couldn't get the
patient to my town,
to Bremerton, within the
90-minute window that you
use for STEMI treatment.
And so actually, we were stuck.
And then what happened, we got
the cardiologist on the phone
and said, we're stuck.
And he said, well, if
you're stuck on that,
the next best thing is to get
him the thrombolytic drugs as
quickly as possible and
then get him to Bremerton.
So we came up with
plan B. And plan B,
put together that Monday
day-- this all happened Monday
morning, Monday afternoon--
was to focus on the patient.
And the patient was
the organizing--
everybody organized around
focusing on the patient.
By the way, he had
six organizations
involved in this workshop--
two hospitals, two EMS drivers,
and two cardiologist groups.
And decision was,
the best we can do
is give the patient the
thrombolytic drugs in the EMS
vehicle on the way to Bremerton.
OK?
And basically, we put the
hospital where the patient was,
is what we did.
And the big hangup was, who
pays for the thrombolytic drug?
Because it's $3,000.
They've never gone
to the hospital,
so the hospital can't
be billed for it.
The EMS company has no
authority to bill for drugs.
They can only bill
for transportation.
So we had a solution,
but a complete blockage.
We brought in senior management.
And the CEO, right
there, Vic Dirksen,
said, this is the right
solution for the patient.
Do it.
We'll figure out
how to pay for it.
And we really needed that.
Without that commitment that
he would pay for the drug--
that happened here.
Then the team put together
the new protocols.
Here's the mock-up kit
for the thrombolytic drug
that's going in the ambulance,
training materials, and so on.
And by Friday afternoon,
we got by everybody
we needed to do this.
And by Friday afternoon, the
protocol was established.
But it took about two or three
months to train the medics
and to make sure that the
hospitals were ready for it,
and all that.
And that's now the
protocol in my community.
And there are articles
about how many lives
it saved in my community.
OK, that would have taken two
years to do by any other way.
So that's one way to do it.
I just want to ask,
how does change
take place in your
organizations compared to this?
You're mostly students.
But how about--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EARLL MURMAN:
Jennifer, I could ask.
OK, good, and I'll
Jennifer, because she--
AUDIENCE: In our resident,
internal medicine residency
program, we were pretty active
in [INAUDIBLE] going along with
lean thinking, maybe not the
formal process on how much
the interns and residents
were walking out each day,
going back and forth between
floors, caring for patients,
and then trying to move towards
a more geographic lean system--
so things like that that
affected our work [INAUDIBLE]..
So it was kind of doing some
trials and then going back
and see if [INAUDIBLE].
EARLL MURMAN: Not
as focused as this.
AUDIENCE: Not nearly
It took a long time.
EARLL MURMAN: It probably
took a long-- that long, yeah.
Yeah, Martha?
AUDIENCE: I was
just going to say,
working in a lot of
under-resourced areas,
the way it really seems to work
in real life is that it's based
on a branch, or a regulation,
or a staff shortage,
or a work-around, is how change
happens because it has to.
EARLL MURMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Catastrophic
event [INAUDIBLE]..
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah, or a
catastrophic event, yeah.
Laura, what about
the [INAUDIBLE]??
AUDIENCE: Well, I'm
at the medical school.
And I teach a course with
first and second year
medical students.
And that course, is
constantly evolving.
So they do a lot of real-time
changing based on feedback.
But I'm not so sure
that that's always--
it was maybe a little bit
too rapid, with not enough--
enough real evaluation
of what's going on.
EARLL MURMAN: But this is
still a fairly small group?
I mean, how many people--
AUDIENCE: The class is--
well, there's about 100
students in a class.
And the class manages both
first and second year class.
So about 200 students total
are managed in the class.
And then, when there
are other problems that
need to be changed, it
does take a long time
to actually change the
facilitator's manual
to actually institutionalize
some changes.
So in some ways,
some of the changes
take place in a rapid fashion,
based on the student input.
And then some of them,
actually, because the process
has to go through
the dean and whatnot,
it actually doesn't get done.
EARLL MURMAN: And well,
it sometimes just dies.
AUDIENCE: It just dies.
There's a lot of talk, and
then it kind of fizzles--
a lot.
And I even think, in
residency, there's
a lot of ideas that come out.
And then they just fizzle away.
Because nobody has a real
time to actually dedicate
to seeing the process through.
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah.
So you can't do
this for everything.
Because this takes a
real focused application
of resources.
So you have to do it for
the most important things.
AUDIENCE: Dartmouth has a really
complex and wonderful quality
department.
AUDIENCE: Yes, so the
TDI can handle it.
AUDIENCE: A TDI that can handle
a lot of these kinds of things.
If you go to them and
with a proposal, and they
can put a team together.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
So I'm speaking specifically
about at the medical school,
what I'm working
with at the hospital.
Yeah, the TDI works closely
with Dartmouth Hitchcock.
And they do a lot of
some lean and some other.
You would know more.
But they incorporate a lot of
continuous quality improvement,
methods--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE],,
things that are,
I mean, for many years,
before they call it lean.
EARLL MURMAN: We had
an interesting thing.
And I keep drawing on
my health care system,
because it's my base
of firsthand knowledge.
But we had an urgent care
clinic and a regular clinic
in the system.
And for financial
reasons, it was
decided to co-locate them
and physically move them
and that they would
share examination rooms.
And these are two groups which
had never worked together.
And the groups were not happy
about this, this new one.
So they had a three-day rapid
process improvement workshop.
And I was fortunate to
go to the final report
out on the third day.
And the nurse from the
clinic started by saying,
Sunday night--
the thing started Monday
and finished on Wednesday.
She said, Sunday
night, I didn't sleep.
So I came into this
Monday morning just
knowing this wasn't
going to work,
that the whole thing was
just going to break down,
and we wouldn't be
able to work together,
and that there was no way we
could share examination rooms.
And she came in totally
convinced this wouldn't work.
By Wednesday afternoon,
she and the staff
in the urgent care clinic
were the best of friends.
They had worked through
all their issues.
She said, this is
just remarkable.
Now, can you imagine
how long it would
have taken for that to
happen, if they didn't get
this intense environment,
with the facilitators
and the objective?
It probably would have died.
Or either that or it would
have been dictated by the CEO--
we're going to do
it, in which case,
they would have not had
any ownership in it.
And it would have always
been a burr under the saddle.
So it's really amazing
how these things work.
AUDIENCE: I think that
the times that I've really
seen change work
in our department
is when, unfortunately,
it's mandated.
Because we have a
lot of people who
come with particular interests
and establish relationships,
people who have decided
not to get along,
people who have decided that
they don't want to collaborate,
who have just created their
own separate worlds that
spin in parallel
laws of duplication.
And it really wasn't until
the chairman of the department
was sitting at a table in
a meeting that was called
and basically said,
this division of labor
is unacceptable, and
we all have to change,
that change actually happened.
And then, once that
mandate was there,
people decided that they were
going to try to get along.
But unfortunately,
the top-down--
the bottom-up
approach didn't work,
and it had to be a top-down.
EARLL MURMAN:
You're lucky you're
in an organization where
the people eventually
decide to get along.
Because there are a lot of
organizations where people say,
we'll just wait till
that guy moves on.
There really is no bonding.
So you're very
fortunate on that.
Yeah.
OK, so anyway, this
is a proven way
to implement change,
where you've got
multiple stakeholders involved.
But you've got to do it right.
And there's a lot of
dynamics going on this week,
that you have to have
somebody skilled to see.
OK, so what we're
going to do is we're
going to do a mock RPIW
for your next change.
We're going to do this five-day
in about an hour and a half.
But we're going to
get to the point
where you're actually going
to implement your new system.
You'll see in a
minute what management
is going to tell you to do.
But we're going to do
it like a mock RPIW.
The other thing
we're going to do,
which is really not as much
of an enterprise thing,
is we're going to implement
a daily management system.
Now, a daily management
system is an approach
where-- in this case, one of our
clinics at 7:55 each morning,
the entire clinic staff
meets for five minutes.
And they go over the
status of the clinic
and what's coming
up for the day.
They have a board prepared.
This is prepared by the
clinic administrator.
So it would be like
the scheduling person.
Here is the previous days--
just like in the New
Balance chart, basically,
the New Balance thing--
the previous days
by provider, how many people
they were expected to see,
how many they actually
saw, all the way down.
And this part is
the upcoming day,
how many people are scheduled
and how many open spots there
are.
This is feedback
from the patients.
This is feedback from
the workforce staff.
I mentioned they track, did
everybody go home on time
with no work to do?
If not, why?
And there's some quality
metrics they track.
So the clinic administrator
gets this all prepared.
There's a stopwatch
here somewhere.
At 7:55, she
punches a stopwatch.
The meeting starts.
At 8 o'clock, it goes off,
and the meeting's over.
It's not really a meeting.
It's--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] puddles.
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah, yeah.
I've heard it--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah.
And here's the staff.
And this gets everybody
in line for the day.
And many times,
we'll come out as--
find out, well, we've
got a patient coming in,
and we don't have all the
paperwork ready, or something.
So they get on top of that
right away and get that done.
So we're going to, I believe--
am I right?
See, we're going to try to
implement daily management
system here, too?
OK.
So right now, the people in the
clinic don't see what's coming.
Right?
Only the scheduler
knows what's coming.
OK?
So we didn't know had three
gray bodies coming in.
OK?
We're going to get that up
where it's very visually
available to everybody
in the clinic,
and you can track
it in real time.
So the wrap-up is
that optimizing lean
at the local level is
a good place to start.
But you can only get so far.
And the biggest problem
we have right now
is that some of your patients
aren't getting treated,
and there's nothing
you can do about it.
So we need to
solve that problem.
And I think there are going
to be some other disruptions,
that management is thinking
about, we have to implement.